in this video we will showcase to you
the monsters that dwarf and make
godzilla earth
the biggest version of the g-man to look
like a small lizard in comparison let's
start with stating the official size of
godzilla earth
so he is 300 meters tall and weighs a
hundred thousand tons
and was a mixed reptilian planned kaiju
that emerged in the 21st century
and later got rid of humanity and then
20
000 years later he grew to be this
monster that ruled the planet
so anyway let's see this list of movie
and gaming monsters bigger than him
just a warning though we won't include
monsters from books and comics and not
the monsters
that are around the size of planets and
of course the ones that are bigger than
planets
so at number 15 we have cthulhu this
great old one has been seen in many
games and more recently in movies and
shows like
underwater and southpaw although this
creature is stated to be in the range of
hundreds of meters tall
no one really knows his exact height and
the reason for this is that cthulhu
can control his size to be whatever he
wishes to be he could be just 9 meters
or 30 feet tall as seen in the show's
gameplay
or around 90 meters or 300 feet tall in
the movie underwater
and more than 300 to 400 meters or 1000
to 1
300 feet in other games like the call of
cthulhu
this would put him a little bit taller
than godzilla earth
at number 14 we have the titans next we
have the plethora of titans as seen in
the game god of war 3.
although only a few were named and
actively seen like oceanus
hyperion gaia and cronuts these titans
were rightfully called so as their
height
ranges between 400 to 500 meters or
between 1
300 to 1 600 feet tall this would mean
that the titans were
around 100 to 200 meters taller than
godzilla earth
but it wouldn't mean that they are more
powerful than him in the game however we
can see
clearly how big they are as the
character craters had to fight enemies
on the titans hands and all over their
body
number 13 chronos this next entry is
also a greek titan but from another
franchise
and looks completely different cronus is
the main antagonist of the movie wrath
of the titans
and he is the father of zeus poseidon
and hades
krona's current physical form is
composed of lava and molten rock of
lines
of lava surrounding his body mouth and
eyes which would suggest that the inside
parts of his body
is completely composed of lava itself he
is also capable of projecting massive
waves of lava from his hands
and with his size of 500 meters or 1640
feet in height
he would be 200 meters or 660 feet
taller than godzilla earth
at number 12 we have the adamantois this
creature is a recurring enemy in the
final fantasy
series it is a large turtle with high
defense and strength but sometimes with
low magical defense
or capabilities later entries in the
series include the larger adama matrixes
that utterly dwarf the earlier parties
that are fought as super
bosses in final fantasy xv the
adamantius reached its biggest size at
713 meters long
or 2 339 feet but with an unstated
height it could have been anywhere
between 400 to 500 meters tall
or around 1 300 to 1 600 feet
it is the largest and the oldest living
creature known to man in the series of
games and said to have been born at the
dawn of time itself
number 11 the exog star wars the empire
strikes back the exogoth or collectively
known as the space slug was a gigantic
species of toothed gastropod
they were silicon-based life-forms that
survive in the vacuum of space
by making their homes in the caverns and
craters of asteroids
they fed on minerals of asteroids
various stellar energy fields
other space-based life forms ships and
other unfortunate creatures that
unknowingly passed into their mouths
although normal ones are small the
biggest ones could reach 900 meters or
almost three thousand feet long
three times the height of godzilla earth
at number 10 we have sirte
serta was the ruler of masspelheim
prophesized to be the one to initiate
ragnarok
sutter was successfully defeated by odin
before who stole from him the source of
his power
the eternal flame before banishing him
and his entire race to muspelheim
in the movie ragnarok loki resurrected
him with the eternal flame and used him
to defeat heller
the fire demon then fulfilled the
prophecy of ragnarok by destroying
asgard
along with heller and himself in the
process just before thrusting his sword
into asgard
he was anywhere between 0.5 to 1
kilometers
or 0.3 to 0.6 miles in height
number 9 the reapers the reapers are a
highly advanced machine race of
synthetic organic starships from the
game mass effect
these reapers reside in dark space which
is the vast mostly starless space
between galaxies
they hibernate there dormant for 50 000
years at a time
before returning to the galaxy and
consuming everything these giant
machines
are ancient and their true name is
unknown reapers were just a name given
by the protheans the previous galactic
power 50 000 years before
these reapers are gigantic organic
monster ships of one to two kilometers
or 0.6 to 1.2 miles in size three to six
times the height of godzilla earth
number eight parallax the parallax
entity is a demonic looking parasite
tick
cosmic entity that is the sentient
embodiment of fear in the emotional
spectrum
its creation came at a dawn of existence
and traveled from world
to world and causing entire
civilizations to destroy themselves
out of fear and paranoia but in the
green lantern movies parallax was
created as a result of the guardian
of the universe corona becoming
possessed and corrupted by the yellow
energy of fear
it was seen that parallax could envelop
cities and it would be anywhere between
two to three kilometers
or between 1.2 to 1.8 miles across
number 7 kalros this next one is also
from the game mars effect
and they are called treasure malls they
are subterranean carnivores spend their
entire lives eating
or searching for something to eat they
are enormous violent creatures that
burst up from the ground without warning
when disturbed
they reproduce via spores that can lie
dormant for millennia
and are robust enough to survive
prolonged periods in deep space
and atmospheric re-entry karl ross is
the biggest of them all
with a total length of 2.98 kilometers
or 1.85 miles
and almost 10 times the height of
godzilla earth
number 6 yorman gander from the game god
of war foe
this creature called german gander is
also known as the world serpent
this is a mythical jotun serpent but
seen active
in the game and destined to fight thor
in ragnarok he becomes an ally of
craters and atrias in the game after the
pair
awaken him from deep slumber within the
lake of nine
as only his head is seen and even at
that it was anywhere between
60 to 100 meters or between 200 to 330
feet across
so by extrapolating his length using
dimensions of normal snakes
his total length would be anywhere
between three to five kilometers
or two to three miles long at number
five we have the leviathan
on the fifth spot we have another
organic spaceship monster called the
leviathan
and this one is from the game starcraft
this leviathan is an airborne and also a
space-borne zerg breed
and for those who don't know what the
zergs are they are a swarm alien species
with
psionic powers and they consume every
living thing in order to attain genetic
perfection
the leviathan is one of these species
incorporated and mutated to fulfill
a purpose of transport this alien
monster
is 6.7 kilometers or 4.1 miles long
or more than 22 times the size of
godzilla earth at number 4 we have the
cloverfield monster
first seen in the movie cloverfield the
monster was said to have come from the
atlantic ocean
where it was awakened by submarines sent
down to the depths to investigate
this monster later emerges out and
rampages throughout manhattan
destroying the city in its path it was
said to have been a baby at that time
and the adult form was seen in the movie
clever field paradox
and the ending as towering above the
clouds even
while standing in the ocean so this
monster could have been anywhere between
five to eight kilometers
or between three to five miles tall or
sixteen to twenty six times taller than
godzilla earth
number three the summer of vermont the
sumo vermin
were gargantuan space-faring beasts with
tentacles and multiple eyes
they developed in the academy's
maelstrom and were embedded in legends
of what
travelers may encounter often
misunderstood
due to their monstrous size and
voracious appetite the bees are a staple
of legends passed between ship
captains and crew these monsters are
rare but the one encountered in the
movie solo a star wars story
was almost beyond comprehension in size
later officially stated to be
7.4 kilometers or 4.6 miles long
number two the rift worm the rift worm
is a gargantuan annelid creature from
the game gears of war
this monstrous worm dwells deep in the
hollows of the planet sarah
and is worshipped as a god by the
inhabitants they were massive worm-like
creatures that were eight to ten miles
long or twelve to sixteen kilometers
long and half a mile
or eight hundred meters across they were
semi-intelligent creatures
and created the hollows by burrowing
through the cross of the planet sarah
and created life inside the hollows
it could easily swallow three godzilla
earth standing one
on top of another and number one
ghidorah
the top spot goes to the arch enemy of
godzilla earth himself
the enemy ghidorah is a monstrous entity
that takes form of a golden three-headed
dragon
and inhabits the void between dimensions
ghidorah has used supergravity to
consume countless worlds
throughout the millennia he is a
gigantic golden three-headed dragon-like
creature
with two bat-like wings at his sides two
legs and two long tails
he was seen coming out of portals and
the neck seemed to stretch out to
forever but luckily the official stated
size
of 20 kilometers or 12.4 miles for this
ghidorah was given
so that's that and we have come to the
end of the list of movie and gaming
monsters bigger than godzilla earth
there were other creatures like the
apocalypse beast and caligon the black
and others that were appeared
only in novels and comics that were not
included
so we will try to make another list with
just these in the next time
so take care be safe and subscribe for
more monster videos